this is what the streets of umur man
suburb of wuwi now look like the
aftermath of battles between the
Sudanese Army and the paramilitary rapid
support forces or rsf homes and shops
all riddled with bullet and artillery
holes all destroyed since the rsf
entered the district nearly 5 months ago
until recently W nuwi was a battlefield
between the Sudanese Army and the rapid
support forces here in umur man nearly
all of its residents have been displaced
as a result the Sudanese Army Now
controls it and is pushing to regain
more grounds from the fighters but the
district that was once vibrant now
carries the scars of the
conflict and the sound of artillery and
gunfire a warning that the front line is
not far from where we are ALS sadik
Sheri and his family are the only
civilians still remaining in this part
of the
district he shows us what's become of
his house house which he says was
occupied by the rsf while he and his
family were in it he says the group
terrorized them while they were there
and continue to fire artillery at his
house after they've left it was not easy
but with time I family has adapted to
the fact that we have no way to escape
we are in a very critical situation
without any resources we stayed and we
tried to adapt ourselves to hearing the
is everyone of my family I'm sure that
has lost at least between 10 to 15 kgam
of his own weight we're eating one foot
the whole day and one meal a
day the Army's recent gains comes after
months of fighting omdurman is a major
Supply route for the rsf even after a
bridge connecting it to the northern
part of the capital Kum was
destroyed the rsf has been firing
artillery to try to stop the Army but
civilians have also been killed as a
result of what local committees describe
as indiscriminate shelling as the
fighting continues so does the
destruction and the loss of Civilian
lives hia Morgan Al jazer
umman Alex dwall is the executive
director for the world peace Foundation
at tus University he joins me now uh
from Boston in the United States thanks
very much for being with us so um we
just we got an idea there of just how
dire the situation has become uh in
Sudan the number of people killed the
number of people displaced and so on and
the toll that it has taken on civilians
there so I guess my question is what is
it going to take to get these two forces
to the table and and bring this conflict
to an
end well so far the the efforts that
have been made by the International
Community by the United States by Saudi
Arabia by Egypt by East African
countries have signally failed neither
side has really shown any interest in
serious peace negotiations on the side
of the government when General ban the
head of the sedan Armed Forces makes a
move towards any sort of concession he
is usually then immediately undermined
by some of his um left tenants who are
islamist veterans from the former regime
and when uh General HTI head of the rsf
makes a some sort of rhetorical public
statement in favor of peace that is
contradicted by the the atrocious
behavior of his fighters on the
ground let let's try to St take a step
back then to to to hopefully understand
this better but what what do you think
gave rise to this conflict and how does
that help us um get get to where we are
now well potentially at root it is a
power struggle between these these two
men and their and their respective
factions now as the war has gone on the
external backing has become extremely
important so so Egypt backs bur burhan
but more significantly the United Arab
Emirates is very heavily invested in in
supporting General HTI and what the the
peace efforts thus far have failed to do
is to bring those external power backers
especially the UAE to the table in some
way and until that happens the the the
war unfortunately is is very unlikely um
to be resolved and and and the this
terrible humanitarian toll the
destruction of Sudan will just continue
a
pace so what do you think outside
parties outside actors I mean you
mentioned the the United Arab R there
what what what can they do to try and
bring this conflict to an end or what
have they not done to this
point well I think the the the key step
needs to be taken actually by the United
States whose um ostensible allies are
the power Brokers behind the scenes now
if the road to any serious negotiations
in Sudan runs through Cairo Riyad and
Abu Dhabi then the United States and it
need to to bring um heavyweight
political actors such as the president
or the National Security advisor to bear
on this these are the voices that will
be listened to in these these capitals
it's not good enough for us ambassadors
to African countries to be running
around they simply don't don't have the
the weight and this is the problem that
is also faced by the East African
leaders such as the Kenyan President
William Ruto who has been the most
energetic and committed he needs um very
serious backing from from Western Powers
if he is to get the the um the Arab
countries in line with his peace plans
good to talk to you Alex the wild thanks
very much for being with us you're very
welcome